the latest gronivirus numbers show
germany has had a dramatic spike
in new cases over the past day the
country has hit a new high of nearly 30
000 cases and nearly 600 people have
died
the highest daily total yet weeks of
partial lockdown haven't slowed the
spread of infection enough
much tougher restrictions seem almost
inevitable now
with political momentum building for a
harder lockdown over the holidays
only two weeks to go until christmas the
looming question across germany is
will a hard lockdown come before or
after the holidays
at its weekly briefing on wednesday
germany's robert koch institute said it
was alarmed
and that it was bracing for a
significant increase in case numbers
the situation could easily tip again
leading to rapid
exponential growth
the situation is especially problematic
in assisted living facilities
according to german authorities
residents of nursing homes are at more
risk than ever
currently we're seeing double the amount
of outbreaks in assisted living
facilities than in spring and every
outbreak affects a lot of people
several german states are now
considering tightening the measures
already in place
berlin's government is considering
closing all non-essential retail before
christmas
the busiest period of the year winter
break may be extended
and schools could return to distance
learning
i believe these two and a half three
weeks will give us plenty of
opportunities regarding disease control
state leaders are now hoping to set out
a coordinated plan
in a meeting with chancellor angela
merkel
the gathering looks likely to take place
on sunday
we're very interested in getting
together as quickly as possible
in order to rapidly gain clarity about
the path
our country will follow
in light of recent developments
religious services over the holidays are
also being scrutinized
if there is a possibility of a religious
gathering
endangering lives i'll be the first to
call things off
the so-called most wonderful time of the
year now marked by deep concerns
a new lockdown in germany isn't a matter
of if but rather when
dw reporter julia saldelli joins me now
uh julia give us some perspective here
how worrying are these
latest numbers they are definitely
concerning um just even if especially if
we consider
that there are measures in place to try
to contain the spread of the virus
and just yesterday the head of germany's
disease control agency
said the situation is worrying we could
even see
a spiraling of of cases again
going into exponential growth the
the virus is widespread across the
country and what is most worrying is
that we see
an increase in cases in older age groups
these are the age groups that are at
higher risk from covet 19
and that's why we've seen an increase in
intensive care beds
and in deaths recently now even if we
compare germany to other countries
for example the u.s which is not seen as
a beacon of
um of responsibility in dealing with the
pandemic and not a successful
example necessarily we see that the
incidence of coven 19 in the u.s
is at 63 cases per 100 000
inhabitants over seven days in germany
that number
stands at 149.
julie as you well know germany
introduced a partial lockdown at the
start of november
it certainly doesn't appear to have
worked so what exactly went wrong
yeah the partial lockdown is not working
it was meant to bring down cases
significantly before christmas so that
measures could be
slightly relaxed over the christmas
holidays and people could
enjoy the holidays better that has not
happened
if we look at uh countries in europe for
example
ireland or belgium they implemented a
tougher
shorter lockdown which was able to bring
cases down significantly and almost stop
the virus in its tracks that has not
happened in germany that is also because
there was not
political consensus around tougher
measures to
be implemented uh in the last few weeks
and therefore we
only saw a partial lockdown come into
effect but that is starting to change
now with these really
uh worrying numbers what measures are
likely to be taken now
so we've seen already some states
implement
measures in this past week
we are looking at the recommendations
of a germany's academy of science
we are likely going to see the school
holidays
extended for by a week until january
10th
we are looking at shop closures
non-essential shops
remaining closed and
we will wait for a meeting between
uh merkel and the sixth angela merkel
germany's chancellor and the 16 state
leaders
to decide whether to go ahead with a
national
common approach with with the rules the
question is whether they will come
into place before christmas or right
afterwards we have to keep in mind that
it is an important time of the year for
shops it's the christmas
buying period so it is going to be a
difficult decision to take
julia saudelli thank you julia
and europe still has a long wait ahead
for vaccine regulators will meet just
over
two weeks from now on december 29th to
decide if the buy intact pfizer vaccine
is fit for mass distribution
but the german government is already
planning the epic task of how to deliver
the vaccine across the country
dw correspondent tess of author reports
the arena in berlin was well known for
its rock concerts and techno parties
now it's slated to house one of six
vaccination centers in berlin
so far there isn't much to see but
everything is scheduled to be ready by
mid-december
project manager albrecht is convinced
things will run
smoothly we timed the process
we allow four minutes for each person to
get in
take off their coats sit down and roll
up their sleeves
then the vaccination team comes in they
disinfect
inject and put some gauze on the wound
the last step is the documentation
that's it here the vaccinated people
will then be looked after by doctors and
nurses
the patient doesn't have to pay their
health insurance covers the costs
first the elderly will be vaccinated
then medical personnel than everyone
else
right now more than 300 of such
vaccination centers are being built
throughout germany
the government hopes this system will
simplify logistics
and make it possible to vaccinate
millions of people in the shortest
possible time
people probably won't be able to get the
jab from their family doctor until
springtime
before that they will have to go to the
center
i think we'll have to wait for hours at
the vaccination center
thousands of people will be there i
don't care whether i get vaccinated at
my family doctors or the vaccination
center
i would prefer going to our family
doctor because they know
about my medical history and will take
any risks into account
dr zabila katzenstein agrees she was one
of the first berlin family doctors who
specialized in treating covert 19
patients
vaccinating people as part of her daily
routine when it comes to covet 19
she says she should be allowed to
vaccinate in her own practice
vaccination is a matter of trust it's
important to know the patient because
every patient reacts differently to
unknown risks
i think the general practitioner is best
equipped to advise
each patient in making a decision about
the coronavirus vaccination
she believes she and other family
doctors in germany
can handle the vaccination campaign
independently
in my opinion the vaccination centers
were probably not necessary
if france can vaccinate its population
using family doctors only
why can't germany germany has opted for
vaccination centers
siberia katzenstein argues that the best
answer is personal consultation
two roads one goal vaccinating as much
of the population as possible
as quickly as possible
let's take a look at some other
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
an experimental vaccine developed by
french drug maker
sonify and britain's glaxosmithkline
has shown an insufficient immune
response in clinical trials
the companies hope to come up with a
more effective drug by the end of 2021.
australia has cancelled the production
of its own covert 19 vaccine
after some trial participants returned
false positive results
for hiv the government said it would
order
other vaccines to make up the shortfall
and researchers say
the global response to the pandemic has
driven a record
seven percent drop in annual co2
emissions
the u.n says they have to continue to
decline at that rate for the next decade
to reach international climate goals the
u.s appears on the verge of approving
the country's first coronavirus vaccine
an expert panel of scientists and
doctors have reviewed information on the
shot
and are recommending emergency use of
the bayern tech pfizer vaccine
their endorsement paves the way for the
country's food and drug administration
to issue the necessary final approval
once that happens the first shots could
be given within days
regulators in britain and canada have
already approved the biotech
pfizer vaccine for use in their
countries
joining me now is dr peter chin hong he
is an
infectious disease specialist at the
university of california san francisco
dr chun hong welcome to dw um a panel of
experts has endorsed the biontech pfizer
vaccine
so what has to happen now before it's
formally approved
well the advisory panel endorsed it by a
vote of 17 to 4
so the expectation is that in the next
24 to 48 hours
we should have the official emergency
use authorization
which will then lead to people being
able to be
immunized in the first week okay
so let's talk about next steps how
quickly could a vaccination program
start
and what exactly will it look like
well there is a prequel so to speak what
uh where there are a few hospitals that
have been given
uh the authorization to begin uh
amongst the earliest and these are the
healthcare workers
emergency room staff intensive care unit
staff people who do diagnostic testing
that's in the health care setting and
then in the
community there will be vaccines rule
out to
drug stores to schools um and then
they'll begin distributing the
department of defense has its own
distribution
so you can see that multiple different
layers and pipelines to get
vaccine in the united states doctor i
have to say depending on who you talk to
where you are
it's easy to get the impression that
there are equal measures of excitement
and skepticism around the world
when it comes to this vaccine what's the
attitude among the american public
well the attitude is increasing uh in
approval
slowly uh in summer it was 50 percent
afterwards thought that the vaccine was
being used for political capital in an
election year
then the approval rating went up to
about 60 percent
in the last month or so we're hoping
that it's higher
but again a lot of it was admired by you
know the
the current administration
dr peter chen hung thank you so much for
your time
thanks so much for having me
indonesia received its first shipment of
covet 19 vaccines from china this week
as the government prepares for a mass
inoculation program the vaccine
developed by sinovac biotech
will be evaluated by the indonesian food
and drug authority for emergency use
indonesian clerics are also expected to
issue a halal certification
for the experimental drug president joko
widodo says
these are only the first steps and more
doses are on the way
we are also still working to get 1.8
million
doses of vaccine to arrive in early
january of 2021
apart from getting the finished version
of vaccines
we are also getting 15 million doses of
raw vaccine
within this month
and later 30 million doses in january
that will be processed by the
state-owned pharmaceutical company
biopharma and indonesia isn't the only
asian country looking at chinese
vaccines rather than western options
made by pfizer bioentech
moderna astrazeneca and others synovac
and china national biotech group
recently announced approvals for
late-stage clinical tests in bangladesh
and pakistan
chinese companies have been mostly
conducting tests overseas
given so few covet cases in china itself
for more we're joined by dr jerome kim
director general of the international
vaccine institute in seoul
their partners include the world health
organization and the gates foundation
among others dr kim there's been so much
news about the pfizer bioentech vaccine
and the astrazeneca one
and then along comes this cynovac
vaccine and i feel like we haven't heard
that much about this one
what do we know
yeah so we we haven't heard in general
about vaccines
that are not you know western mainstream
operation warp speed
but you know uh chinese vaccine
developers including synovac
synopharm and kansino have vaccines that
have advanced into advanced stage
phase three testing for safety and
efficacy you know synovac is one of the
companies
if you look at its vaccine it generates
what we call neutralizing antibody at a
level lower than a scene
for astrazeneca for instance or johnson
johnson
but it does generate the neutralizing
antibody and it also
uh has a study where their vaccine
protected monkeys against infections so
you know from a hypothetical perspective
you would say that this vaccine
has a chance and it would be very
interesting to see their data when
they're announced i
i think it's supposed to be later this
month
so their data has not been announced in
the same way that for example the pfizer
drugs
information has been made available
yes and i think it may be something
peculiar to the way the chinese system
is set up because
both synovac and cynofarm uh have
results that have been submitted
their their files have been submitted to
the chinese regulatory authority the
nmpa
for approval and neither company has
commented on their phase three efficacy
now we did hear about phase three
efficacy for synopharm
from one of the sites conducting a trial
in the uae yesterday
86 for cynofarm but we don't
have any other information about this so
it was and cynofarm itself has not
commented so
i think it may be something about the
way the system is designed
to handle efficacy data well i think
we just saw shipments of the sinovac
vaccine to
indonesia and while china has done a
stellar job combating kovid
that wasn't the case in the beginning
and there wasn't much transparency
when covet 19 was still a mystery
mysterious illness so i think it's
reasonable for a lot of people to wonder
about its vaccine development efforts
given general transparency issues
stereotypes about corruption connected
with the state what would you say to
anyone worried
about the sinovac vaccine particularly
indonesians who just saw
the first shipment arrive in their
country
you know i think that the we have to go
with the data and
and i guess we will have to trust the
national regulatory
authority in china the nmpa to review
the safety and efficacy data
the way they would review any vaccine
and and we know that
synovac and cynopharm both have vaccines
that are approved by the who
pre-qualification mechanism
which allows those particular vaccines
to be sold to un agencies for use around
the world
so both companies have experience with
the un
based who system for approvals and you
know i think when they commit
to providing vaccine to covax which is
the global
uh vaccine allocation and distribution
mechanism that 190 countries have signed
on to for covet 19
um they're committing to who
pre-qualification
right i think that the uh what's going
on in sorry in
in in indonesia is actually they're
planning to test
in effectiveness trials a number of
different vaccines including canned
cyanosinovac and cyanoforms so
indonesia is actually planning a rollout
of those vaccines
and very quickly you're in south korea
what vaccine is the government there
buying
actually the government here it was
announced a few days ago is actually
looking at
a number of different vaccines so right
now the only firm contract is with
astrozenica
but they've also indicated a desire to
purchase
from pfizer biontec from moderna and
and from johnson and johnson as well as
getting their vaccine
allocation from the covax mechanism
so they're hedging with a group of
vaccines dr jerome kim thank you so much
for your time
you